foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
total submission
these guys had a little uh
they coming from a bigger ranchers so
they're a little bit
wild they're not used to be touched and
handled by humans
and uh for them to turn around and
just lay down like
really in total peace answering the
calling
definitely
the power of the word gets clearer and
clearer after you see
more and more submit
[Applause]
this is total submission
total submission this guy is ready for
anything
to be done to him and he's not nervous
he's not resisting
he's in total relaxation
no panic hormones whatsoever
yeah let him go he gets up they weighed
over 300 pounds
and it's usually getting way more now
because
he's fed and he's been having fun
bismillah
[Music]
i'm putting only a finger on the ear
and this guy if he wants to get up i
don't think any
anybody is capable to get him back down
he's totally answering the calling
and he's happy with it there's no
breathing hard if you know this
the lungs is not breathing hard he's in
total submission
[Music]
same reaction they all react the same
the power of the word
[Music]
they're more religious than most humans
[Music]
hmm
do what you can stop worrying about what
you can't um
and again you go to hell you go to hell
i'm just playing um if you think you're
going to go to hell
it's probably because you're not doing
everything you could be doing so
i do say do what you can don't worry
about what you can't but
what people think they can't is often
much smaller than what they actually can
we feel me like people think they can't
do a lot of things
but trust me nothing is farther from the
truth
brothers and sisters welcome back to the
realest podcast in the dunya
you are here with the host the three
muslims
and today we're gonna be basically
touching on
what is why is it specifically haram
besides the fact that allah says that is
haram
what can we gather what can we say
in terms of testimonies in terms of
experiences in terms of
actual evidence and uh
all that good stuff so we'll pass it on
to romney
and inshallah yeah man
in general a lot of non-muslims watching
this so for them
what is halal meat halal meat
is meat that is slaughtered in a very
specific way
halal means permissible so anything
that is permissible for you to eat that
salad in a halal way in a permissible
manner you're allowed to eat
so the way we slaughter the animals in
islam is
usually we can include a snippet of it
there's a lovely video out there but
brother
he basically submits the animal he
covers its eyes he doesn't
show the knife to the animal he doesn't
show the slaughtering to any other
animals
the animal doesn't know what's going on
it's just calm relaxed peaceful
he recites a dua or he starts reciting
something
and he slits the jugular he
cuts the throat of the animal this will
drain the blood from the animal
um and it's actually from what i hear
it's painless since they cut this
they actually don't feel any pain from
the from the the cut or anything
and the blood flows out and uh this is
done in the name of allah and then this
for me this food is hard for you to eat
[Applause]
is
this is all submission
total submission this guy is ready for
anything
to be done to him and he's not nervous
he's not resisting
he's in total relaxation
no panic hormones whatsoever
see i let him go he gets up
what's up
all right somebody growing up in the
west says
i can't really find halal food near me
um
i'm tempted to go to mcdonald's get in
on this quarter pounder
what do you tell them um i would say
avoid mcdonald's just for the sake of
avoiding mcdonald's
nasty uh then i would say um you can
find the best alternative and
i mean this pre pretty much food like
everywhere if you
really really can't find it then you're
you're basically
exempt but you should try and find the
means of getting halal food
if it has to be imported if you have to
buy it and have imported for yourself
whatever the means whatever it is uh
we're also allowed to eat food
slaughtered by
jews and christians as long as it's done
in the name of god um but
don't go to fast food they're like like
the worst uh it says in the quran that
you're not allowed to eat
the food of animals that was killed by
another animal that was like pushed and
it died from like
fall damage um you're not allowed to eat
the food of
i don't know if it's funny bro what's
funny fall damage
i don't know why on hill on her laughter
i know bro like what is this call of
duty
yeah it takes one is the last time we
all found the last time we all hopped on
some cod
a while it's been a while it's really
been a while uh
but it's literally been a month bro yeah
it's probably going to be another month
yeah yeah so um
we're not allowed to kill uh animals
that like fell to their death or sorry
not
to eat from animals that fall from the
death they're not allowed to eat from
animals that would like trampled over so
on and so forth
basically anything other than this if
you watch the videos they you see that
they literally just
like shoot them in the head with
something to kill them and um
the problem with this and if i could
talk more about this the problem with
that
is you're leaving all the blood and all
the toxins and everything that's in the
animal you're just leaving it in there
and these animals could sit for a little
bit before they're actually you know
chopped up and they use
the the the bones and the carcasses of
these animals
and that's what you're eating about this
the the patties from mcdonald's you're
not eating the meat
they sell the meat they they leave they
have the remains the carcasses the bones
and all the other stuff that they they
they reduce
to this patty and then they then they
sell you that patty you're eating bones
yes very um it is the most disgusting
thing ever that's what eating when you
go to mcdonald's
but if i can you tell us more about the
um
the blood-borne diseases and the
problems with eating um
from animals that have the blood in them
and more and pork more
more specifically yeah man look it up uh
blood
is the greatest germicide but at the
same time
so many nutrients right i think it's 97
but
i'll be sure to link it up 97 of
bloodborne
uh viruses or all viruses are bloodborne
right so
complete perfect uh thriving ground
that's how they spread
um and basically islamic soldering
soldering
it drains the blood as much as we can
right
you don't need a genius to know if you
go to your your butcher shop
and you check out some normal ground
beef and then you find the packaged
halal beef
you'll see there's way less blood and
it's for a reason right um
but yeah that's that's essentially the
tldr
yo and throwing in some uh new age stuff
here
back when i was into the new age stuff i
used to
think uh you know how in science we
learn
energy cannot be created nor destroyed
it can only be transferred
well supposedly you look at these
animals right this is the time when i
went vegan
and look at these animals the way that
they're getting killed
um there's a lot of negative energy
like they know that something's about to
happen they're squealing they're crying
they're
they're going all crazy and everything
they're panicked bro they have all this
cortisol that's being
dumped into their bodies and then
they're being killed
with all that cortisol all that negative
energy and if if this law is true
that energy cannot be created nor
destroyed it can only be transferred
that means that
the energy is being transferred into us
when we eat this meat
i mean allah doesn't let us eat dead
animals for a reason
yeah and bro if you think about this if
that is true if what i'm saying is true
here
think about the animal running off a
cliff and then falling to his desk
taking that fall damage you might think
to yourself ooh
perfect i ain't had to do no work i'm
just gonna hop down here
and i'm gonna chop them up and i'm gonna
eat them like dude you don't think this
animal as it was falling to his death
had just this dump of cortisol in his
body
you don't think you had a dump of
cortisol when it was trying to run away
for dear life
like and and you look at the halal way
of butchering the animal when
they put the ears over the eyes or they
just put the hand over the eye
they literally start reciting everything
but the moment they bring the animal
down to the ground it'll
it'll kind of go crazy for a little bit
but i mean come on think about it what
living thing wouldn't go crazy you see
an insect
bro you put an insect on its back and
it'll start going crazy you know what i
mean so like the animal will go crazy
for a second but then when you cover the
eyes
and the the butcher starts reciting you
the dua or
a verse from the quran like brother
animal is in
full submission
foreign
total submission
these guys had a little
they come up with bigger ranchers so
they're a little bit
wild they're not used to be touched and
handled by humans
and for them to turn around and
just lay down like
really in total peace answering the
calling
definitely
the power of the word gets clearer and
clearer after you see
more and more submit
perfectly still yeah no cortisone no
nothing
and then they kill the animal and the
animal doesn't squeal or anything it
doesn't cry
it has no fear so it's like if the
animal is dying like that then it would
make sense
why a lot meat is permissible and why
any other form
of meat is haram it weighed over 300
pounds
and it's usually getting way more now
because
he's fed and he's been having fun eating
alfalfa and everything he's probably 10
pounds larger than what it was in the
office
i weigh 190 pounds so any dealing with
this guy he has to help out
otherwise there's no chance anybody can
really restrain him or force him to do
anything
that he doesn't want to do he's going to
do exactly what he
instantly wants to do
so if this guy submits the power of the
word is clear
this is a 300 pound animal for me to
drop him down on the floor
to start submission it's almost
impossible
for one person to do it i'm gonna ask
abdul ahad to help out
for the initial submission and then he's
gonna withdraw and the animal is gonna
respond by himself
[Music]
okay
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'm putting only a finger on the ear
and this guy if he wants to get up i
don't think any
anybody is capable to get him back down
except two people as strong as me and
abdullah
to be able to submit this animal on the
floor but now
he's totally answering the calling
and he's happy with it there's no
breathing hard if you know this
the lungs is not breathing hard he's in
total submission
[Music]
same reaction they all react the same
the power of the word
[Music]
they're more religious than most humans
there's actually no cortisol secreted in
the blood in the body
from any glands bro um from the kidneys
where stress hormones are induced in an
animal that's that's getting uh
completely submitted to allah just from
allah's word
um you can see how calm they are they're
arrested um we'll already put these
clips in so they'll see it by now
uh so it's not anything out there but
you know what i was gonna ask you about
before ramen goes back in
you did an interview with this channel i
think was propane fitness or something
yeah and it was something like x vegan
turned carnivore
you did this before islam didn't you
yeah
and you were talking about the halal
meat slaughtering in that yeah how did
you know
um actually the the patron
that you were telling me about amar
which i have to hit up because i haven't
hit up since you told me about him but
he was my
client at the time and me and him were
talking about some things
in regards to islam and he was telling
me about the halal meat
and then when i watched it i was just
like whoa like that's
that's pretty insane how this this
animal is like 400 pounds
it's literally just in full submission
and the guy's not trying to like hold
the animal down the animals literally
just
literally just ready and i think i
i didn't at the time i didn't understand
it but now
now that i'm like in islam like i do
understand it a hundred percent
man yeah
yeah probably so now that you said
the whole thing about halal foods or
halal meat
meat why pork why is pork
so bad for us why is it such a
haram food possibly one of the worst
aside from blood
the message popped up that said you were
not muted i'm like damn i did it again
but uh yeah so first and foremost when
answering these questions it goes back
to what you mentioned in the beginning
uh because allah said so allah is the
most wise allah is the most
knowledgeable
what he says goes what he says is true
so if he says that you shall not eat
you know pork or pigs then you shall
only eat porking pigs
and there's a reason for that so
um from what i hear
i i forget the statistics to be honest
fired i hope you know more about this
than i do but um
uh there's something that has something
to do with obesity like
i'm not going to talk about things i
don't know about to be honest but it is
uh
if you look up the studies and i can i
can pull up now if you look at the
studies you could see how unhealthy it
is pigs and
heart disease i will but like how it's
linked to heart disease and obesity
and and all these uh these health issues
that arise so um
i'll take over bro while you're doing
that yeah it's just like triglycerides
and with the content bro but it's not
it's not good fats bro
and it's just a process the way you eat
pig
nobody eats pig like people eat
pepperoni
or pork or like sausages and all these
things that
i don't want to go a little into but
it's like oh pigs
the whole thing about angel saying
energy can never be created or destroyed
it gets converted from one form to
another
um it's one of the laws of energy and
thermodynamics but
pigs eat their own feces bro
pigs eat their own feces they they bathe
in it they like go
in it and it's like they're eating that
and then we're eating them
how is that different than us eating our
own feces bro
i don't know that's how i always looked
at it yeah what you said
rings true it's like no one just eats
pork
you know and like a lot of spanish
people yeah a lot what pork is pig
swine it was really
pork pig it's fine
bro i had no idea i thought pork is like
a type of like a way of eating pig
i thought pork was like kind of like how
you got like fried chicken from chicken
so i thought pork was like a type n i
don't think so i think pork
is just like i i think that's the name
of pig like the pig meat
okay like like you know how there's
steak from cow
yeah i thought that's pork from pig yeah
that's what it is but pig is one
biggest one yeah yeah as far as i'm
concerned
but um ah bro you don't confuse me here
but listen a lot of latinos will
probably chime in and be like yo
like actually in the past um i did eat
pork
you know like i'm speaking for myself as
well and it's like
dude the pork is only good when it's
prepared in that certain way
and even then like you have to mix it
with other things in order for it to
truly be enjoyable where it's like man
i remember one time i i went to the
supermarket
and pork was on sale for like a dollar
something
a pound and i was like
at the time i didn't have much money so
i'm like oh
[Music]
i'm about to go in but i bought like
five pounds of pork
for like five dollars bro some rice some
eggs some oatmeal bro you know
peanut butter the the bodybuilding type
diet right
and as soon as i'm like cooking this
stuff it was so
bro it was just so rough like i couldn't
chop it apart i'm like what the hell is
this
and then when i finally got done cooking
it i think that was the worst tasting
thing i had ever
tasted in my life just the pork itself
and even i tried adding some seasonings
i tried mixing it in with the rice i
tried adding like
some tabasco some barbecue sauce bro
nothing wallahi nothing
works so it shows that like these
restaurants and these places that
are cooking the pork they're probably
adding msg
if i'm saying that craig you guys know
what msg is yeah
i don't yeah okay romney msg is like
it it's almost like a not it's not a
spice but you would consider this
yeah it's a tasting salt bro and it is
not good
it's not good for us but it makes things
taste
so much different like chinese food is
predominantly
msg yeah what's even more versus msg
stands for monosodium glutamate
but there's other names because big
farmers
you know knowing this and food
manufacturing
like companies are knowing this so
instead of
msg they'll write maltodextrin they'll
even write this thing called natural
salt
and flavoring how does it occur
naturally occurs naturally in their labs
for sure
but they're going to put that in and
there's actually i think i read some of
those 51 plus names
for msg that you can find in your
ingredient list so they know what people
are looking up for now
so it goes to show that like if you
really want to eat clean
and pure like you have to have the most
simplest
whole food ingredients yeah yeah
so but getting back my bad for cutting
you off but
i got to finish i got i got to get to
the point so uh getting back to what i
was saying
if you go to a place and you buy pork
then more than likely using msg
and some other stuff to try to make it
have some flavor in and of itself but if
you just cook the pork
by itself and try adding like salt
pepper
maybe a little bit of oregano maybe some
garlic maybe some onions
stuff like that listen it's not gonna
taste that good
not as good as maybe beef or lamb
or chicken you know and i just
damn i had a point bro i had a point
it's all good bro i had a point i'm
gonna run me take over if you can
because i think how much more time you
got
i got uh less than eight minutes go for
it then
by all means i'll take over if you do
remember
i'll just wait till romney's about to go
all right then i guess you're gonna miss
this bro you're lost mommy
all right all right actually no no go
ahead though
all right so this is a uh actually wait
wait wait wait hold on
not go ahead bro yeah go ahead go ahead
uh from drax.com
basically uh six five or six reasons why
you can eat pork so firstly is the
pig's problematic digestive system i'm
not gonna go through all of it but like
i mentioned before increased cancer risk
from bacon and other processed
pork swine flu in humans um
[Music]
i'm gonna pronounce this wrong
tri tri trichinosis dangerous
and um it's true gnosis trichinosis
thank you
thank you i'm playing with you i don't
know oh my god this guy how's it going
this guy's a doctor over here
and fifth pigs harbor common viruses and
parasites
so just a few things like um they store
the toxins in their fat
and then you go and you you know you eat
that why would you want to do that
um also a lot of these pigs that we've
mentioned before since they're not halal
meat they're not slaughtered
ways meaning the blood remains inside um
increased cancer risk um
there's i remember reading something
about obesity and and eating pork
but uh i remember that so i'm not gonna
mention that but i think there's
something
similar related to that but that's
basically it do your research go look at
the studies go look at the reports
i'm not gonna make it i'm not i'm not
gonna say this to be
racial or anything like racially by the
same
races but it's just something i've
learned you know if it's a
generalization so be it but growing up
i would eat a lot of different foods
because i love trying different cuisines
right i'll be going on middle eastern
south asian
east asian african caribbean
you name it greek and what i've noticed
is
when you look at obviously like you know
afghan you know shawarma these places
lebanese they're not gonna have pork
obviously but
i found that asian so whether it be
japanese
chinese korean vietnamese bro they be
going in
on pork and it's almost like every
single dish has pork
and i'm not saying this like they do but
i have friends growing up and
well they'd be going in on pork every
single day i would know people that
would bring
pork and rice and they'd just be eating
it and when i go to these restaurants
like because i love sushi
i love you know chinese food and when i
go i see that pork
not only is it the cheapest one
available but it is literally in
everything like if it says something
like steam-fried dumplings or it says
something like
spring rolls there's always pork in them
like i have to always ask what's in it
they're like oh there's porky
i go to like a greek place it's like
this nice mediterranean platter with a
little bit of pork and it's like bro
come
take the on out
take the pork out
what about a little bit of cross
contamination yeah yeah so it just goes
to show like how disgusting polk
actually is
like the fact that they roll around
their feces they eat their feces
and then you know they're not killed in
a lot of way they have all the blood
still inside of the blood is harboring
all of these
harmful uh pathogens then bro now on top
of that you got all the pathogens stored
in their fat
all this nasty stuff stored in the fat
and like bro
the fat is what they are most known for
bacon is most known for the fat that's
why
people love bacon so much and here you
are eating something
that's the most disgusting piece of food
available in this dunya dude
and like i was telling y'all my stepmom
had ate some pork belly with some bacon
and had
bacon on top of the pork belly i'm sure
it tasted good
i'm sure it tasted real good but you
know what that food poisoning she had
afterwards
i'm sure that wasn't too good and she
was food poisoning for like two months
straight
it wasn't like oh a 24 hour 48 hour they
know it was like a two
month straight thing where she was
vomiting
and had diarrhea almost every single
day i remember after those two months
she went vegan
or vegetarian or pescatarian for such a
long time and i still think to this day
she does not eat pork so if that is not
divine intervention
i don't know what it is yeah subhanallah
well and you got to look at society in
jail like we're literally
going against allah that's that's what
society's doing that's what we're moving
mainstream society and with all this you
know
consumers type of culture and all you
see everywhere it's like
you don't see cheese pizza and then some
some other stuff like chicken you see
cheese and pepperoni hell you'll even
see pepperoni before cheese pizza though
yeah you know everywhere pork is
literally before everything
you know yeah i used to love pepperoni
pizza bro
but anyway the reason i was bringing up
my my vietnamese friends and all that
um and my chinese friends in school i
would always see that right and i was
like damn y'all really go in
but i didn't really know that i thought
it was beef because it looks the same
and it was like it was like coated and
they were eating with rice and there's
one day he's like yo you should try some
bro i was like oh yo i'm down bro
and he's like he's giving to me and has
right before i'm eating i was like
yo is this uh is this hello he's like
what is that and i was like
bro like because growing up always was
lost so i thought everyone did i don't
know
he's like bro it's pork bro i don't
think pork there's a lot
i was like bro i was like this close to
like eating and i was like
nah bro i'm not doing that bro and this
man just kept doing that every day and i
was like
enjoy bro but something told me inside i
don't know if it was my parents voice or
whatever but
i just stayed away from that bro yeah
that's good um i do gotta go now
uh my class is starting soon so uh may
god bless you both
and i'll see you guys soon
my guy i think we've covered everything
for halal and haram food
and this is something else t2m
t2n the second release podcast in the
dunya
the two muslims over here with your boy
fired
and we're gonna make a new channel real
soon
don't tell rami though yeah if you made
it this far type in hashtag
t2m 2m and we will get our new channel
going
um and we've already made some videos
but it was just me and you
honestly bro i feel like the vibe is
different you feel me the vibes are
immaculate
so could be why not bro why not
yeah hey hashtag t2m
hashtag come up hashtag out of pocket
hashtag we in this hashtag
is can you recall any other thing
similar to haram meat pork anything like
that that you feel like
you want to bring up and talk about any
experience at all like we are
we're allowed to eat not just halal meat
that's not pork but there's
meats that could be healthy meats that
could not be allowed so like we can't
eat
like you know like dogs
and like cats i only say that because
like i've seen some videos bro
i'm not going to name name any countries
but going on dogs
cooking them lives too but uh i've seen
that we can't use
recipients and stuff like that i know
it's messed up but it is what it is
that's my point it's like we can't just
eat any
meat has to be ones you know allowed for
us
then we have to you know have a whole
lot of slaughtering um obviously no pork
so
there's there's people hitting us up yo
uh can i have halal pork well that's not
really a thing you can't have gloved
pork that's like you think can i can i
drink
wine i've seen places i've seen places
where they they try to be like
oh halal and they had pork underneath
and it's like ah
good try you seen places bro i've seen
places that
label pork halal like uh the street food
type
places pretty messed up where the where
i like downtown orlando
maybe it was a joke bro i don't know bro
shout out to florida period bro cause
y'all be going in with the happiness
of the civilized ish and letting people
do what they want and not really doing
lockdowns in canada we have a stay at
home order bro
you leave the house you're gonna get a
ticket you're gonna get a fine
damn you will be questioned while you're
leaving the house
i think there's a hundred thousand or so
you guys can look up if you really care
vaccines and refrigeration and i think
they're giving like a couple hundred per
day
and it's like bro why are you just not
using them all
right and then they're broke our
province of ontario
which is kind of like a state in the
states for people that are like what the
hell is the province
um our province of ontario
has literally written a letter for a cry
for help to all other provinces in
canada
saying send us your positions and send
us your extra icu bins like we're
literally at capacity
you remember that whole thing being pre
covered they're like we're you know two
weeks to flatten the curve
so the health care system doesn't get
overwhelmed we reach that bro in ontario
isn't that crazy and they're not
supposedly like oh back schemes are
going to
stop it or help it um and they're not
even giving out these vaccines
as fast as they should be supposedly
we're going to keep having these uh
vaccine restrictions
where it's like you you know how like
now you need the vaccine to travel
and like supposedly now you need the
vaccine to do high no you don't need a
vaccine to travel but you need a vaccine
to do hutch
and omar like to go to pilgrimage yeah
well
supposedly a lot of people are saying
that it's gonna get to the point
where just travel anywhere you're gonna
need to have
the the mark yeah so hashtag mark bro if
you made it this far again but
yeah that was in a different video bro
do it again this one it's not going to
say the same thing
um it's not going to say the same rule
applies for every country
but what i will say is it depends on the
country so
i have heard of what you're saying like
countries requiring uh
vaccines but it's not like a
prerequisite like you can enter without
it but then you need a pre-covert test
you need a cover test on arrival you
need a cover test within the first
five to six days and that's in iceland
i'm literally just talking about iceland
do you remember when we went to iceland
in february of 2020
no cover test mask on plane but you know
we didn't even do it whatever bro
you iceland there you want to you know
kind of come after me now go for it
i don't wear my mask in the plane bro i
didn't care about that i just
dozed off and well me and you hit up we
landed in
in iceland no covert test no
restrictions
died in eating bro we literally ate at
restaurants we ate some good thai food
with no with no mask
we went everywhere and we came back now
you need
free to leave the country in canada the
kova test
shove that up your nose in other parts
of the world they're doing anal swab so
hashtag
don't even have to take that
make the sound there we go there's uh
there's other you know wild stuff like
you know once you land you need another
test and then you need a test couple
days later
you need to then self-isolate for i
think 14 days
and when you come back you need a cover
test before leaving
once you come back to canada you need a
corporate test after and once you return
to canada
you need to pay 2k to quarantine
at a government designated hotel
facility
um 2k per person that is ridiculous
so you're going through all that but
here's also what i was going to get to
iceland now offered this thing that you
were talking about called the vaccine
passport
where if you are marked you get to leave
canada
go to iceland no tests no quarantine
no self-isolation you do whatever you
leave
it sounds enticing but what are the
drawbacks
like what are the drawbacks over time as
well
this is not bro there's been studies
showing like blood clots
in like people in canada i don't know if
you know if you've heard that or not
i have not heard that i heard that it's
making some women in the photo
oh i've heard that too yeah um but i
looked a little bit into that and i
found out
there were a lot of like hoax things
from that like there was no
proper literature but i found literature
for like blood clots it's not just
literature the government literally put
out a thing
like oh this vaccine causes blood clots
in
a lot of people so now it's not
mandatory for anyone under
i think 55 but bro why is it even
mandatory for people under 55 to begin
with
i'm i have cousins that are 16 17
posting you know status on facebook with
their vaccine report
saying alhamdulillah shot once
if okay if it causes blood clots
wouldn't someone that's over
55 years old be more at risk of
developing blood clots than somebody
wouldn't do yes they would be but but
supposedly they're at more risk of this
clovert thing
but they're not at risk of um blood
clots which
makes no sense because i know people
personally like i'll give a thing
i'm not trying to you know give any
false news or anything
or talk against this whole pandemic
but what i will say is my grandmother
back in bangladesh
she was straight bro no illnesses no
issues
no nothing right she's been top tier
health
and what happened was she
got into the hospital for something i
don't remember what it was
but you know all those stories about
nobody gets diagnosed with covert until
they show up to the hospital
you know how many people it says they
went into the hospital for this then
they got diagnosed in the hospital with
covert
it's kind of sauce but she went in there
with that within the same couple days
obviously she had a vaccine and
everything right she got spondylosis
for your spine she got dementia
and she got some other uh different um
you know stuff for her body like
different medical diagnosis and i was
like
bro what
huh what happens in spondylosis
it's just uh it's just uh she she had
spondalus and she has spinal desiccation
those are the two words
but uh bro we're on a time crisis right
now because brother gabriel is hitting
me up
um even though we're short on time
um i was gonna get to the main other
part two
uh my roommate right the brother i live
with bro shout out to you if you're
watching this
um my roommate's dad god
um yeah thanks thanks for always naming
everyone's name up bro what would i do
without you
frigging clown um his dad got the cover
vaccine
right after getting the vaccine man's
been in perfect health by the way right
trust me um after the vaccine this guy
has um i forgot what he has
he's been getting tingling um numbness
in his fingers those are the first
couple days
then he basically lost sensation it was
like slight paralysis from
of his complete right side of his body
which was weird because he's never had
these things right
and they diagnosed him with a couple
stuff i think they diagnosed him with
spondylolisthesis
this happened bro and i was just like
huh like he was in perfect health and
now
he's just he's just chilling bro
alhamdulillah he's doing a little better
but
it's weird bro like when we don't need
this we're not supposed to be out here
with
all these all these extra external
you know foreign interventions for our
body allah made us in a way to
be straight allah even said that in the
i believe this is in the quran
somebody can quote me on this um or
reference the hadith
but we did not send mankind any disease
or affliction except that we have also
sent with it its cure
not treatment treatment being a drug
vaccine do you think but a cure because
nobody can tell me a vaccine to cure
because
i've heard of people that got the
vaccine and they've actually gone
covered
is it rare yes but it's not a cure then
right um
a cure is something that completely you
know fully eliminate something
um but again that's not the you know
there i say uh we wrap this up
last thing i don't know where i heard
this
and i don't know how true it is but it's
something that people if they're
if they're listening this far then they
can definitely repeat this
and supposedly like depending on what
blood type you are
covet will affect you differently and i
spoke
i remember i spoke to your moms about
this going to this yeah
yeah so um supposedly oh
it's all positive and all negative uh
these people
experience kobe's symptoms the least if
at
all and i have this dude that's at my
gym
that my major and um before i came to
the gym he said that
literally it was like a friday where he
had
rolled spoiled with everyone and then
when he came home
he uh he went into the shower and when
he got the shower
he was like smelling and he noticed he
couldn't smell anything his nose wasn't
clogged anything he just noticed he
couldn't smell
so he like got his perfume tried
smelling it nothing
um then he went to talk to taste a
mountain dew because he had just come
from the gym so he went straight to the
shower he didn't eat or anything
and then when he tried a mountain dew he
said it was like water with bubbles
basically like a uh a seltzer water
he said it was like a social water and
then he looked at his wife he's like yo
you're playing with me aren't you
and then she's like what do you mean and
he's like dude this isn't mountain dew
and then she's like that's mountain dew
and like when he poured it out it was
legit mountain dew
like there was no games being played but
this man went to the doctor um
i think saturday morning
they tested him positive with kovid and
wallahi by monday
he got tested again no more kobe
literally no more kobe no more symptoms
or anything he could remember
elon musk elon musk himself tweeting out
that
over the last 24 hours i've taken four
clover tests two of them came back
positive two of them came back negative
and it wasn't like four different labs
it was like the same test like the same
pcr same lab
what how is that like bro that's like 50
reliable 50 unreliable 50
false positive or false negative and
meaning 50 true or false and therefore
being like
zero percent reliability so
what i'm gonna do and that's coming from
elon musk and he's up there bro he's up
there like
he has a lot to lose you know
but again i say we wrap this up bro
listen if y'all made it this far uh what
i do want to share is if you are worried
about the whole coping thing
vitamin d vitamin c
zinc and blood flow
and water bro yes water because water is
actually
just water but i'm just trying to like
list a few things here
for um people that they can kind of edit
but yes you are right water
um obviously proper sleep uh if you are
in ramadan
obviously you know do these things in
the appropriate times
but understand that these things um
though i'm not a doctor though i'm not
giving you legal and medical advice here
what i have come to find what have i
you know the people that i know who have
had covered and have recovered
extremely fast from covet this is all
that they
pretty much tacked on which was vitamin
d zinc
vitamin c and did i say another one
besides
saying water and besides the sleep
movement moving movement movement blood
flow
blood flow just get out go walking
like dude if you're gonna walk walk for
like two three hours let's say you had
cloven
go walking i mean it's the lowest
intensity form of exercise
that you can think of besides like very
very light swimming
um but to keep it very simple these are
just some preventative measures and also
some things that you could do
if you did get covered to be able to get
past
a lot quicker and again this is not
medical or legal advice this is just
things that i've come across insha'allah
it may help any of you to end it off i'm
not going to end it off like romney and
do not know how to end it off like
romney
but if you have made it this far you
already know the hashtags to put
and we expect to see them uh but we hope
that our conversations may help in one
way shape or form inshallah
and with that being said assalamu
[Music]
alaykum
[Music]
[Music]
hmm